hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting round this is round 22 of
the 1959 candidates tournament here we
had Michael towel with the white pieces
against vasily smyslov and towel really
went all pirate ins missile and in this
tournament in the end the score out of
those four games was in toss favor but a
very important thing you have to know
that before this tournament before the
1959 candidates missile never faced all
over the board so he heard of course
story says you know they're both Soviets
about the magician from Riga the pirate
of Latvia but he never actually played
him so you know this is the first time
he faces him and yes he has to play four
games against him and since I know this
is what you're all waiting for here it
is this is Smith slope versus towel I
believe in the photo is actually from
this game as you can see that Smith had
I believe that's the C pawn you can see
over there and on chess games.com they
actually use this photo on the other
game where it all had the white pieces
but I think it's actually from this game
also has the photo has a nice signature
so it might be from the person who
actually took it as I have no idea who
took it but yeah there they are and you
can see tall's famous stair I have no
idea who the person in the background is
probably probably the guy moving the
pieces on the show board but okay that
being said let's see this game tawa Fogg
was 44 we have c5 and Knight to f3 d6 d4
C captures Knight captures and Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 and isse X now the
shoveling and variation of the Sicilian
Bishop to e2 a 6 tall castles Knight bd7
and now f4 b5 and Bishop to f3 to
prevent this missile from pushing before
so the bishop is now also defending d4
pawn bishop to b7 and now a three again
stopping b4 Queen to c7 and now Queen to
e1 with some ideas of maybe pushing e5
in the future and also the Queen can
always jump to g3 so Bishop to e7 is
always preparing the castle and before
told us anything reckless he over
please King 2h once as when this
diagonal is open you always want to put
your King on a safe square don't wanna
leave it open to any future checks so
rook to b8 and now b3 aspen is love
castles and now we have Bishop to b2
rook after he ate and now comes the
Queen to g3 and you can see that tal has
a nice Bishop on B - he has a queen and
g3 and both of both of these pieces are
eyeing that g7 pawn as sauce missile
goes for Bishop to f8 just to avoid any
future problems and also by playing go
to f8 he opens up the rooks control of D
file and is preparing to push a five top
lace rook 81 and here
like I said Bishop to f8 was I was a
multi-purpose move guarding g7 also
preparing to [ __ ] five and now if you
play something like g6 - maybe activate
your Bishop - via Bishop to g7 then tal
would push a five himself and now your
knight is attacked here there's a this
tension between the light square Bishop
after Knight to d5 and the series of
exchanges Knight captures the Bishop
captures Bishop captures and pawn
captures not all would have this e six
move and white would always be better
here and this opens up the strong bishop
on b2 f5 is always an idea the troops
are very nicely place that the queen is
aligned with the King on the G file so
tal wouldn't make this work so after
okay - e once missile pushes in five
himself so no problems there
Knight to a5 now again pressuring that
g7 pawn also ideas like night to h6
check might be a coming in the future so
King - 8 h8 west miss love and now here
tau plays Queen to h4 an interesting
idea for white would be rook to d1 going
after the d6 pawn because okay the d6
pawn is defended by the Queen and by the
bishop but it's not like the bishop can
move the bishop has to guard the g7
square
so now after something like rook to c8
because after the knight moves you do
want to have pressure on this C do pawn
white can actually capture here but now
black has this g6 move
and you can see that White's idea
doesn't really work with going this rook
to d1 now you can't really move the rook
as you simply lose a piece and if you
move the knight you lose a whole rook
so after rook captures an f6 Knight
captures and the Queen to h4 it's it's
an interesting game but the black should
not have problems defending if you
captured a knight of course Queen
captures and f6 will check so black will
be okay here so I have to key into h8
tile decided to go Queen to h4 we have
it captures on f4 Queen captures on f4
and knife to e5 now rook to e3 with some
future future ideas that when the
special move Bishop moves the Rope can
come to g3 or to h3 g6 by Smith's love
and now comes Knight to h6 and we have
Bishop to g7 Knight to d5 attacking
Smith flops Queen Knight captures and he
captures on d5 and here you have to take
take some things into consideration for
example can you capture the c2 pawn
unfortunately you candy if you grab it
then you get a knight captures on f7
Knight captures on f7 and rook captures
any eight rook captures and now Queen
captures on f7 threatening both Queen
captures and g7 checkmate and Queen
captures rook so after a defend this
rook the g8 Bishop captures rook
captures and now Queen to f8 check
roadblocks Queen to f6 check rook g7 and
now rook to e1 with the terrible threat
of rook to e8 checkmate so after we
block this for example Queen the c8 if
you put me in to see it then you get
Bishop to g4 again if Queen captures
rook to e8 is checkmate you have to
defend this so Queen to Jade but now
comes the Bishop to d7 and there is no
defense against rook to e8 this is just
one of the lines that could happen
although after rook to d1 black doesn't
have to go Queen c8 you can also go
something like h5 but then h4
simply blocking that g5 Square and after
Queen f5 or white still prevails with
the simple rookie a check King h7 and
now capturing the Queen G captures and
rook to d8 and like
white will win this endgame easily the
black black bone structure is simply
terrible your age five points attacked
the d6 pawn is attacked this is an easy
win for white so after this he captures
on d5 you can't grab the seat to pawn
Smith off plays f6 with the idea of
pushing g5 preventing the Queen from
guarding the night and h6 so this would
basically win a piece and Tull actually
allows this he plays Bishop to e4
what's the idea that of course he knows
missile wants to push g5 he will play
then after he moves the Queen rook is
coming to h3 it could get a little
dangerous but again none of these moves
are as as you would say precise
these are all pirate moves we have g5
now Queen to f5 threatening Queen to h7
checkmate and now there are two ways to
defend one is of course to capture the
knight other is to play Knight to g6 but
Knight to g6 doesn't work so if you play
that you get rook h3 and now after
Knight moves to protect the h7 bone
again now you have knife to g4 and this
will this will be devastating as now
there is a triple attack on the edge so
in pawn black first must capture the
bishop to prevent this so after rook
captures now you simply play Knight
captures on f6 again you have a triple
attack on the h7 pawn and after after
something like h6 now you can even play
rook captures and after Bishop captures
Knight 2d 898 opening up I discovered to
check here and winning Black's Queen so
this is this is completely over so after
this Queen to a5 Smith's lab has to grab
the night so Bishop captures and this is
the only good move for black Queen to f6
now this comes with check push up to
back to g7 and now Queen to a5 again
tile threatens checkmate on h7
so Knight to g6 now blocking and now we
have worked to h3 here Bishop captures
on b2 was played removing a very strong
defender Dahl has but allowing Queen
captures on g6
but again cap
vitu was the only good idea for Smith's
level and again you can see that there's
a triple attack on the h7 pawn so rook
to e7 defending and now we have rook to
h6 and this is a this is a true towel
move as mouse missile has to decide what
to play here is missile played rock to
g8 and again this is the strongest move
that plays Queen to f5 and Dallas with
this nice Queen rook idea here talus
preventing moves like rook to f8 rope to
f7 since he's controlling the F file so
although he's down a piece until Smith
slope can stop the attack and activate
his own light square bishop on b7
there's a really really no way to take
advantage of this extra piece so if you
look at it like that it's like tall
isn't down a piece at all he's just like
up a pawn
so bishop to see it now Smith's love
activates this Bishop and now comes
Queen to f3 g4 now picking the Queen
away Queen to d3 now again tile keeps
keeps an eye on that h7 point and we
have Bishop to e5 getting the bishop out
of the way so tile couldn't trap it at
any point will move like c3 maybe maybe
blocking this diagonal we have C 4 by 12
and C 4 is an excellent move in a
position like this when when you're down
a piece and you have really nothing to
do just look at what tall does he pushes
c4 and he creates some chances
ABI captures on c4 we have B captures on
c4 and now it's missile plays rookie to
g7 doubling up on the G file and if you
look at this position it doesn't really
seem like there's anything tall can do
but tall plays c5 a very interesting
idea now of course you can't capture the
C pawn with the Queen if you capture
with the Queen then you get rook
captures or Bishop captures since
there's a triple attack on the h7 pawn
so he plays D captures on c5 and now
comes d6 so again you have problems what
do you do here
Queen to a7 by snakes love and now comes
Bishop to d5 attacking the rook on g8
and again Thal is trying very
but he doesn't he still doesn't have
anything solid here rook to d8 and here
towel plays Queen to e4 attacking the
undefended Bishop here so what do you do
here mister plays Bishop to d4 here
towel plays Queen back to f4 and here
tall has a tall has a pretty terrible
threat here just to show you the threat
for example black played something like
a 5 let's say it doesn't really matter
tells threats Queen to f8 check and now
of course if you capture rod captures
then you get rook captures and you're
getting checkmated but even after Queen
to f8 check even if you play the
strongest move if you block then again
you get Bishop captures and now after
rook captures Queen and the rook
captures now there are again a lot of
threats here one of them being of course
simply rook captures on h7 so after
something like Bishop to a5 defending
and now comes d7 and this this was
Todd's idea at this d7 move this was
this was brilliant now of course if you
capture with the bishop we can show it
you get a row captures on h7 and this is
checkmate and of course if you capture
with the Queen well that's that's that's
no better you get rook to Bishop to e6
opened open I discovered check and
you're losing the Queen
so after King g7 simply Bishop captures
Queen and now black can play Bishop to
d3 since the king is attacking both
rooks one of the ropes is gonna fall
but now rook at for King captures and
after rook captures and G for 3 points
on both sides but a rock against the
bishop will beat the bishop pair so
after this Queen to f4 move this is the
critical moment of the game and there is
only one move that can save Smith love
and allow Smith love to win the game so
do try and find it it's a pretty nice
position for you to analyze as you know
if you play chess you're gonna you're
gonna get attacked so try to find the
best move for Smith love that stop
stalls idea so I do hope you were able
to do it and I will show it after I show
you to move that Smith love actually
played human dispositions missile played
rook G to d7 and he totally missed
idea as in this position tall played
rock to f6 and now there's a problem now
there is no good defense against rook to
f8 missile kind of missed this probably
due to time trouble I really have no
idea but that was often the case when
you played against all its missile
missed that Bishop captures on f6
doesn't work if you capture it then
after Queen captures rook to g7 now you
get Queen captures on dat check
roadblocks and Queen captures and this
is checkmate another thing after rook to
f6
you can go something like back to g7 but
then again rook to f8 is winning you
have to block and now again comes a
bishop captures and after rook after
screen captures now there is no good
move for black here Queen to g7 simply
Queen captures on c8 and you're up a
whole rook is white black cannot afford
to play a queen after Sun g8 because
rook to f8 and it's all over
so yeah after this rook to f6 move
Smith's love resigned at the game and I
said that here I wanted you to find a
move that actually stopped stars idea
because you know it's an excellent
position to analyze if you're able to do
this then you would be able to defend
against a player liked all the moves
miss love missed was actually Queen to
d7 and Queen to d7 it's especially in
time trouble it's like you know you're
not gonna find this because now this
idea is stopped because if now Queen to
f8 check again of course you can't
capture it but again you can play roof
to g8 and now the same idea doesn't work
Bishop captures rook captures rook
captures and now you'll see the problem
now black that has this move King to g7
allowing rook captures on h7 and after
rook captures and King captures rook now
when the queen is on the 7 the bishop
actually defends the Queen so after you
capture the Queen Bishop captures now
black is actually up a piece and winning
the game this d6 pawn alone can't really
do much so this is a nice variation
Smith's love missed unfortunately for
him but fortunately portal at
style really did a lot of pirating this
tournament as he wanted so why not show
it another time the final standings of
this tournament
McDowell with 20 points out of 28
winning first place and is ready to face
Mikhail Botvinnik for the World Chess
Championship match and I will show a
couple of more games probably by Paul
Karras as he is the only player who
actually had had great games against
Michael Dahl and had a positive score
against all in this tournament
you know towel could never trick Karras
if he beat him a Hibbert in fair and
square
he carries never fought I fell for
towels tricks so yeah I also showed it
maybe you're new to this channel maybe
you're new to do 99 candidates so you
know you see how the standings are at
the end of the tournament and yeah
that's it
here you can enjoy this photo one more
time I'll stare at its miss love
Sicilian that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank the
matrix Nisbet for a contribution to my
channel think a lot to really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon probably with another
nice game from the 1959 candidates
tournament